des gilets jaunes dans les ronds-points
de corinthe de spartoo d'athènes
impossible il n'y a aucune place pour
marx bourdieu dans le monde d'homère la
question sociale est incompatible avec
l'esprit tragique
[Musique]
les lecteurs peuvent apprendre d'abord
ils peuvent découvrir des mythes grecs
qu'ils connaissent mal une vertu
pédagogique
ils peuvent ensuite ensuite apprendre
que nous nous venons aussi de ça nous ne
venons pas simplement d'un héritage
chrétien au fond morale progressiste
mais aussi nous avons un pied de cette
culture grecque est davantage tragique
[Musique]
50 murs de grecque raconte l'espèce de
mélange électrique qui se produit
lorsqu'on fait entrer en contact les
grands mythes grecs et l'actualité
politique contemporaine donc 50 nuance
de grecs tome 2 est une bande dessinée à
laquelle on trouve à chaque fois une
double page et à chaque fois il ya un
mythe grec sur cette double page dans la
page de gauche dessiné par jules on a
une histoire avec les protagonistes de
ce mythe est dans la page de droite qui
est écrite par mois on a un commentaire
philosophique qui vient en écho par
rapport à ceux des sens est en fait
l'idée d'origine est venue de jules qui
s'est dit je vais proposer à un
philosophe un universitaire en gros de
faire des petites pastilles un peu à la
wikipédia un peu un peu érudite et
finalement c'est pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé on s'est mis à travailler
beaucoup plus à deux et je suis
complètement sorti de mon rôle un peu
sérieux a juste faire des vignettes
explicative pédagogique
on s'est mis en scène dans un véritable
dialogue un véritable échange
[Musique]
ma source d'inspiration en plus bien sûr
de homer et les iodes c'est clément
rosset et son livre la force majeure ou
il est précisément question de cette
joie tragique que nietzsche avait aussi
beaucoup détaillé où il s'agit de
trouver une joie non pas dans
l'amélioration d'un réel que je voudrais
changer mais dans le consentement
un destin que je ne pourrais pas changé
[Musique]
j'aimerais d'abord que le lecteur
s'amuse j'aimerais que le lecteur riz
j'aimerais que le lecteur et les
émotions et en suisse que j'aimerais
qu'ils retiennent c'est que nous ne
sommes pas simplement les héritiers
d'avoir une vision chrétienne
judéo-chrétienne des choses dans
laquelle on espère une justice finale
dans la sphère dans laquelle on espère
une amélioration et une rectification
des inégalités nous sommes aussi les
enfants d'un esprit tragiques grecs dans
lequel il s'agit de dire oui à la vie
même lorsqu'elle est dur
[Musique]